según la ong
Human Rights se concédenoslo al menos
200 son personas han muerto en Irán a
manos de las fuerzas de seguridad en las
protestas iniciadas hace ella tres
semanas estas protestas estallaron en
ese país en Irán tras la muerte de
maxamí que falleció el pasado mes tras
haber sido arrestada supuestamente por
haber violado el estricto código de
vestimenta que rige en ese país salud
vamos a nuestra segunda invitada el día
y a Susana saura filóloga y periodista
además es musulmana Susana Gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo América de
Francia 24 problemas primero de Qué es
el código de vestimenta musulmán para
las mujeres
muy buenas el placer es mío y Bueno pues
sobre este tema de código de vestimenta
de las musulmanas la verdad que es un
tema un poco controvertido porque sí que
es verdad que el islam dice tiene una
serie de normas en cuanto a conservar La
pureza no de la persona unas normas que
son tanto para el hombre como para la
mujer en esto lleva la vestimenta pues
una vestimenta un tanto más discreta de
hecho en la sura 34 en la basura suran
número en el capítulo de la luz en el
Corán sí que habla del hombre y de la
mujer habla de la mujer en cuanto a que
debería debe taparse sus encantos cubrir
con un velo no por encima de los
encantos del escote no dice
splicintamente el uso del jillab de
hecho ya digo es un tema controvertido
porque es verdad que depende la
interpretación que le dé la persona hay
muchos eruditos que de siempre lo han
interpretado como el uso del velo del
hillab en la cabeza hay gente que no
también Es verdad que en el islam pese a
que suene un poco raro decirlo pero hay
libre albedrío porque se tiene como una
religión muy estricta muy basada en
prohibiciones constantemente pero
realmente tiene libre albedrío la
persona puede elegir libremente que
vestir y como vestir sí que digo que hay
que ser discreto en la vestimenta tanto
el hombre como la mujer pero no
solamente la mujer que parece que solo
nos centramos a la mujer y también hay
que decir que hay mucho machismo en el
mundo árabe o persa en este caso hay
mucho machismo mucho machismo cultural o
personal que se mezcla con la religión
se extrapola por eso en occidente se
tiene Esa visión de que la religión
musulmana es machista que se centra en
la mujer en la vestimenta de la mujer
pero realmente no realmente se centra en
los dos en cuanto a conservar esa pureza
no pero pero al final Tienes libre
albedrío y no hay coacción En la
religión lo dice claramente en el Corán
es decir nadie tiene que obligar a
ninguna persona a nada absolutamente a
nada Es decir el hecho de que estén
obligando a las mujeres en este caso a
cubrirse el velo además de la forma en
la que ellos dicen eso no es así O sea
eso sería pecado De hecho no le valdría
ni a la mujer
ni al hombre es decir si el hombre cree
que por eso va a ir al paraíso por haber
obligado a una mujer a taparse para nada
y a la mujer se iba contra su propia
voluntad no le sirve de nada porque una
mujer que realmente quiera taparse que
quiera gozar de esa libertad que también
es otro tema ya parte porque también es
la libertad de querer taparse que en
otros países también se sufre ese tipo
de claro Entonces digamos que los
gobiernos
musulmanes son los que estarían digamos
obligando a las mujeres sobre todo a
vestir de cierta forma por por qué lo
hacen porque no dejan que las mujeres
decidan no como vestirse Cómo se sientan
cómodas con su cuerpo con su vestimenta
Y por qué la represión siempre a las
mujeres en este caso estamos hablando
obviamente de que ya se va a cumplir un
mes de la detención de maxa Mini también
la muerte dudosa tras ser detenida por
la policía hablemos un poco esto
Pues mira es un poco por lo que decía
antes no colación de este machismo que
sufre la sociedad árabe Y persa en este
caso en Irán Es verdad que el hombre los
gobiernos sobre todo pero el hombre en
general usa como herramienta la religión
es decir quiere meter miedo con la
religión ya no solamente que obligan a
la mujer a taparse de cierta manera y no
todos los hombres pero la mayoría pues
se obligan a que se te aprende de cierta
manera Al igual como que quieren que se
queden en casa o que no estudien O que
hagan simplemente las tareas del hogar
pero bien sabemos que eso no es islámico
para nada de hecho sabemos que el islam
bajó en una sociedad que en su momento
era caótica y a día de hoy por pena
sigue siendo caótica Arabia saudí bajo
una sociedad para poner orden
precisamente para limpiar ese machismo
para dejar esa libertad para a la mujer
y al hombre entonces las sociedades
árabes se centran mucho en eso y atacan
a la mujer Pues con lo más fácil en este
caso por ejemplo la vestimenta el código
de vestimenta no tienen libertad
realmente Esas mujeres en países como
Arabia saudí o Irán en este caso que sea
que nos estamos centrando no tienen
libertad eso no es islam no tiene
Libertad para nada también hay que
recalcar que las mujeres se han
levantado en protesta por más familia
pero también por las mujeres que son
reprimidas para cubrirse y las que
también se cubren porque quieren es
decir por esa libertad
porque por ejemplo la sociedad
occidental hablamos de lo mismo es son
dos caras de la misma moneda en Francia
por ejemplo hay manifestaciones de
mujeres que al revés que quieren taparse
pues como una monja que quiere cubrirse
libre albedrío claro y ha decidido
cubrirse porque cree que pasa esto en
países occidentales tomaste el ejemplo
de Francia por ejemplo también muy
polémico lo del burkini no en las
piscinas en las piscinas públicas en
varias ciudades Por qué por qué pasa
esto
Sí pues ahí estamos hablando de lo mismo
o sea es verdad que en los Países Árabes
No sé no son todos pero en muchos países
o islámicos Perdón Porque Irán no es
árabe es islámico Bueno sí hay que
recalcarlo luego están las ramas pero
también hay países que parecen que gozan
de esa presumen de esa libertad que
realmente no tienen imponen ciertos
códigos en cuanto a lo que ellos creen
parece que también Tiene una obsesión
constante muchos países occidentales con
el mundo árabe islámico entonces creen
que la mujer es sumisa por el hecho de
haber elegido taparse Yo nunca he visto
que hayan atacado a una monja en cambio
éramos musulmana sí Entonces yo puedo
entender que por ejemplo en Francia no
quieran o no permitan el uso del burka o
de no técnica por ejemplo porque no se
ve el rostro de la mujer Eso sí que es
entendible porque de hecho en el islam
tampoco te obliga no te dice que te
tapes la cara ahora repito libre
albedrío de mujeres que quieren hacerlo
que lo hagan entiendo que en Francia en
países ambientales eso no lo permitan
pero legislar el velo simplemente pues
vuelvo a lo mismo es como un ataque
constante hacia el otro parece que
quieren separar a la sociedad de el otro
el que no es occidental blanco
está supremacía
esta teoría que tiene siempre no de ir
en contra de ese otro que al final Casi
ya no en ese otro lado como El
desconocido
ese desconocido que al final acaba dando
miedo pero simplemente es por
desconocimiento y al final ves que la
mujer tampoco goza de libertad No a una
mujer no tiene por qué llevar a lo mejor
una minifalda no quiere destaparse
quiere taparse entonces creo que
deberíamos tener en cuenta
en la opinión no O la elección de las
mujeres en general luchar por esos
derechos humanos primero y de la mujer a
todos los niveles muy muy rápidamente 15
segundos y cree que la libertad Es sobre
el cuerpo de la mujer sobre todo en este
caso de la mujer musulmana va a seguir
siendo reprimida por por parte de
gobiernos de hombres sobre todo
Por pena debo decir si esto Esto va a
ser una moda pasajera el hecho de
solidarizarse que occidente o el
feminismo occidental tan selectivo Por
cierto se solidice en este caso con
estas personas con esta causa es una
moda los gobiernos mientras que estén en
frente mientras que se han apoyado por
unos terceros que eso nunca se menciona
mientras estén apoyados por unos
terceros que es la gran potencia digamos
ellos van a seguir ahí al poder y van a
seguir haciendo lo que quieran en ganar
contra la mujer o contra quien
les surja en el momento